divorce this is the show with Sarah
Jessica Parker and you too I would
imagine I mean she's so terrific and I
can imagine you guys having fun on the
set just hanging out do you do you
socialize in real life do I do we do
socialize we're friends and she's just
like everything you'd want her to be
like beautiful she smells good she was
sparkly diamond shoe they're cute jeans
and when I tie was like let's go out for
dinner she was like okay so we went out
for dinner after shooting with a bunch
of girls and Sarah Jessica ordered a
cosmopolitan and we were at this like
cool I wanted to like bump into somebody
I knew that is so great but the greater
you had that enthusiast know you're like
I'm in this TV show are you kidding me
you know and as a matter of fact and
years ago I got a part on Sex in the
City with Amy Sedaris and I was such a
fan of the show that I actually felt
like I felt like a fan from Cleveland
who won a part on a television show and
I was so starstruck by her but um she's
just she's truly like the coolest I mean
I am still that way about a lot of
celebrities after all these years I'm
still you know what I mean it just I'll
meet someone who meant a lot to me and
or you know I I had Christmas party had
people over to my house and Bob Newhart
came and I grew up an idolized Bob
Newhart and I just kept going to pop new
hearts in my house and I was practically
crying I was just so I just I felt like
I had won and I had I had won some kind
of contest and I think it's really good
to be connected to that it's so true and
you always want to say the perfect thing
or I don't know I'm sure you wanted to
say the perfect thing did you go through
your head of what you said to him I'm
like oh I try try not to put too much
pressure on it and so yeah I just said I
thought you were Jewish
and put that silverware back yeah stuff
that got me in a lot of trouble and
heard that I should have given it more
thought
you